what do we know that about this so as
you said this of course involves Chuck
blazer not only a former fifa official
but also he held the number two post at
CONCACAF of course the federation of
football for North and Central America
and the Caribbean as well now he gave a
testimony in a sealed courtroom in New
York back in 2013 this testimony has now
been made public and in it he admits to
using his position to enrich himself
arranging and agreeing to accept bribes
to influence voting for countries hoping
to host the World Cup in 1998 and 2010
now he also accepted bribes from a
sports marketing firm that actually paid
CONCACAF for marketing and media rights
to regional tournaments and admitted he
didn't pay income taxes between 2005 and
2010 in fact in total he pleaded guilty
to 10 crimes at the hearing the most
serious of which actually carries a
maximum sentence of 20 years in prison
now he couldn't be contacted for comment
and his attorney declined to comment as
well a lot of those details we already
knew from when the indictment of course
was revealed last week so what's new
what's caused a surprise so you're right
that in this indictment last week
basically it was referring to a
co-conspirator number one and you know
people insinuated from that that it was
talking about Chuck blazer because it
matched his description it described him
as the general secretary of CONCACAF
from 1992 2011 matching his title
matching his tenure also of course Chuck
blaze has already been named a
whistleblower because there was the New
York Daily News report last year saying
he was actually cooperating with the
government in investigate in
investigating this corruption now this
transcript that's now been made public
hasn't actually stated wear the Blazer
was cooperating with the government but
what's really new is just the level of
detail marking I'll read you a bit of
the statement from what he told the
court I knew that the funds involved
with the proceeds of an unlawful bribe
and I and others used wires emails and
telephone to effectuate payment of and
conceal the nature of the